Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Roberto Minelli
Buonasera!
Questo breve appuntamento di TEDxLakeComo
ha come titolo "Il buon uso del mondo".
Un titolo che abbiamo preso
da un bel libro
del professor Salvatore Natoli,
che a sua volta mi ha confessato
di aver preso da un'espressione
di Emanuele Kant,
il famoso filosofo tedesco.
È un bel titolo, perché contiene in sé
un auspicio, una raccomandazione,
un invito, e anche una conclusione.
Sarà il titolo della nostra manifestazione
che faremo a novembre:
sabato 5 novembre ci sarà
la terza edizione di TEDxLakeComo.
Questa volta ripeteremo l'edizione
nell'auditorium del Politecnico di Como,
come negli altri anni.
Se ci domandate
perché abbiamo messo insieme
filosofia e musica,
la risposta è molto semplice:
perché sì, perché ci sembrava
una cosa molto bella.
Se ci domandate perché l'abbiamo fatto
alle 19 di sera, di maggio,
ve lo spiegheremo alla fine della serata.
Se ci domandate
perché una brava, giovane pianista russa,
e un filosofo italiano,
vi rispondiamo: perché viviamo
in un contesto globale,
Elina è molto brava,
e il professor Natoli
è un affermato pensatore.
Allora,
incominciamo con Elina Cherchesova -
ha un cognome molto difficile.
È nata in Russia, in una città
ancora più impronunciabile,
vicino a Mosca.
Ha ottenuto il diploma a pieni voti
nel Conservatorio di Mosca,
e vi suonerà Prokofiev.
Perché Prokofiev?
Perché è un compositore eclettico,
appassionato, energetico;
e il buon uso del mondo,
come poi sentirete,
ha bisogno di fantasia, di energia
e di grande passione.
Elina Cherchesova!
(Applausi)